edel et les filles il faut que je vous
parle
papa est parti vous êtes disputer non il
va revenir et pas bêtise zoé avarie
partie avec la poule du salon de
coiffure
il reviendra pas prendre part mais
qu'est ce que je t'ai fait tu m'as fait
que mon père s'est cassé parce que tu es
moche et chute en même temps tu me diras
bon démarrage j'ai jamais compris comme
on le faisait pour supporter sera témoin
ça fait longtemps que je saurai si tu as
la porte en pense quoi
moi je sais pas imaginer que demain tu
te retrouve tout seul du travail
comment et où tu arrêtes des séries tu
n'as capable mais j'ai un travail je te
rappelle que je suis chercheuse au cnrs
et toi iris raconte qu est ce que tu as
fait de passionnant cette semaine j'ai
commencé à écrire tu écris nous savoir
sur quoi
c'est l'histoire d'une femme marchandeau
deuxième ses claques sur tous les sujets
possibles et imaginables il a fallu
cupic juste lu ta soeur
mais alors qu'est ce que j'ai appris il
paraît que tu écris un roman ton
histoire de femmes marchent en droit
canadien
mais c'est minable tu m'as toujours tes
que c'était rigueur le moyen âge j'ai
besoin d'écrire gens crèvent d'envié
oui j'y arrive pas j'en suis incapable
et alors et alors tu vas écrire ce livre
tu sais si c'est nul c'est elle qui va
tous se prendrait pas moi et si c'est
pas un nul et ça marche